Denver where the Nuggets
Championship we are celebrating the
family man 9489 is the final your mom in
here oh come on mama don't go upset yet
Mama come back
here though uh two-time NBA champion
you're the only one of these guys who
really knows how to celebrate this what
tips do you have this look like they
already they had a great you know tip
you know they already knew how to
celebrate uh but now I'm just
overwhelmed uh I'm excited for my
teammates to get their first
championship and also my second uh and
then also just to be a part of History
I know you're excited about both
obviously I'm not asking you to pick one
or the other how how different were the
paths from the Lakers to this Denver
team for you uh
I don't think the past will be like like
different you know we ought we had to
fight all the way through the playoffs
uh and make it to the finals uh but just
the the difference is I would say uh
it's just the experience you know we got
the experience with the crowd I got my
family my kids I got a chance to
experience them come on stage with me uh
and also I get a chance to uh experience
the uh the parade so I'm looking forward
to it and you talk about that experience
you have that experience from that first
championship was there anything you said
specifically in game or before game to
let you guys know what it's like to try
to close out in a championship level
environment uh yeah I mean for me it was
all about defense you know that's what I
leave my hat on defense no we got to get
stops uh no defense is going to win
that's a championship and I always told
them that uh it's going to win us a
series and a championship so we got to
continue to uh defend take us through
the play on The Butler pass in your
steal which we're going to see here in a
second okay I know you're not seeing her
right now you're gonna see it in a
second you also have three blocks by the
way but take us through what you saw in
that that play
um for me uh just just staying close to
my man you know uh Duncan Robbins is a
great three-point shooter you know he he
great all coming off screens uh but that
was that was true standing you know so
the screws is the same way yeah but just
trying to stay close to him um and yeah
Jamal had a
uh Butler cover so just stand out back
to my man and then um you know he just
threw a careless pass and I was there
you know so many people will be watching
tonight and have watched and they see
the celebration they see the
championship moment they see the
champagne they see the trophy
tell them a little bit about the journey
to get here from Detroit the teams
finally getting here and then you and
Bruce you know winning I mean just talk
about how that feels and but you know
really let the young kids know the hard
work that you put in to get that sweet J
you got yeah
I mean yeah I work hard you know in the
summer times you know just no get my
work you know lifting you know my shots
you know I got a shooter coach with the
lethal shooter you know and we've been
at it for the last five years so you
know the last how many years five kids
y'all hear that last five years so like
and you know it's all about just
preparation you know I prepare myself
you know for these moments uh in these
games and
no I always I told my teammate I told
them all early you know uh late in the
fourth quarter you know Big Time moments
for Big Time Players yeah you know and
we showed up tonight
kcp you know when you were acquired here
it was a perfect fit from all of us
looking your three and D guy understand
how to play without the basketball when
you first got here in training camp did
you see it the same way that you guys
and you can fit this perfectly oh yeah
I've been telling the guys from from
jumps even like a couple of my friends
I'm telling back home I was saying if
Jokers don't win his third MVP we're
gonna win a championship yeah you know
what I'm saying I I could see it in the
guys you know that was hungry training
camp you know and then just me bringing
that mentality over over here and then
also them giving me the opportunity to
to voice the uh that the opinion so I
mean I felt like they made it home for
me you know and I just fit right in hold
on you
said if Jokers didn't win his third MVP
you thought you guys won the
championship we was going to win the
championship
expound on that what do you mean why do
you think that was because I I feel like
he deserved that third MVP you know uh
the way he's been playing uh and the way
he's been carrying our team my man hey
oh my man so uh but yeah know it was
just a feeling that I had before
training camp and you know during
training camp you know being with my
guys and just experience everything with
them and I felt like that you know he
was going to win this Championship if if
Jokers didn't win his third MVP okay
let's introduce the guy smelling like
champagne all right
everybody's got the same place
they get ready you know we talk about
the players talk to me about Coach
Malone you've had a lot of coaches what
made him different in this situation for
the Denver Nuggets uh for for me uh he
gave all us the opportunity to to voice
our opinion on on defense offense on
what we see because we out there playing
uh he gave us that leeway that dialogue
with him the coaches uh so everybody had
that dialogue so and then we just tied
into that um
that just helped us out a lot you know
just getting to know everybody uh
opinions on what they think on how we
playing kcp we're gonna let you go I'm
told we've got something to look at here
before we bring uh Bruce in what's that
uh-oh
Georgia baby yes sir
kcp we got a lot of UGA people back in
Atlanta so I feel like I feel like
they're gonna win their third
Championship too so it's gonna happen
yeah I feel it congratulations go enjoy
with your teammates congratulations
Bruce Brown has sat down can you hear me
all hooked up over there
um there was a celebration afterwards
you guys both came in together did you
have a sense of how that could impact
this franchise the additions from the
outside of Smitty was just saying we
could see how the parts sort of fit and
made sense in terms of missing pieces
what did you see yeah um when they
called me they were like uh we're trying
to play defense this year um we got to
get better on defensive end
um and in my position I needed to prove
myself on both ends of the floor
um I thought Denver was the the perfect
fit for me
please talk to a little tell him oh my
man everybody coming up in here there
you go
talk to the folks a little bit about
just again we've talked about your
journey and and you said something that
I think was remarkable you know for a
young player when you said hey I needed
to get better in terms of shooting so I
need to work on my shot and then you
became a great shooter in this league so
just talk to the fans out there and
particularly the young kids watching
about how you got here because all they
see is the the championship moment right
yeah I definitely had to put in a lot of
work when I came in my first year I shot
25 from three and teams are leaving me
wide open I was a muck guy yeah I didn't
like that at all yeah I didn't like that
at all um the confidence wasn't there um
I didn't like that um I wasn't myself
out there on the floor and as you know I
like to attack and get to the rim um but
I couldn't do that um so I had to get in
the gym uh 6 a.m was my uh when I
started 6 a.m two a days right away
um I didn't take any time off after the
season
um I had to get back to it you know
introduce Aaron sorry Aaron well he's
got to wait right now we're gonna ask
him a question yeah all right you're all
right I'm good yeah
[Music]
you know with the Brooklyn Nets but you
played a lot of point in University of
Miami post Malone put you back at
playing making plays with the ball
you're in how much confidence did I give
you
uh he literally told me to go out there
and play play your game
um and then all the guys was like bro be
aggressive that's when you're your best
uh get on transition shoot the ball when
you're open
um so I mean this team was amazing for
me um it was a perfect spot for me
I was gonna let you sort of introduce
Aaron by telling us what he meant to
this series because we talked about in
our pre-game the opening minutes of game
one when Aaron had the mismatches
against smaller Defenders and Joker was
able to find him sort of set a tone for
this series yeah obviously this series
was huge he produced me well but it was
the whole playoffs in the whole year
um he guarded the best one of the best
forwards out there
um this playoffs um it doesn't get any
better than those three
um but I mean he's a Workhorse he's a
dog down there he's literally
Unstoppable down there in the paint and
when he's hitting threes nobody can
guard him um so everyone thank you Aaron
Gordon
we wouldn't have been able to do it
without Bruce and come on man don't get
it twisted
so Aaron let me let me ask you this
question this
this is your second Championship your
first one was with the Oakland soldiers
got got a shout out to Oakland soldiers
right yeah exactly and then you come in
here into Denver and you and you drop
another one right talk to us about the
feeling that you're feeling right now
and and what it means to for you and
Bruce to bring the first championship to
Denver in the NBA just Joy just ecstatic
like just for excitement joy happiness
and static God is good
um Bruce talked about like the 6 a.m
workouts 6 a.m two a days yeah you know
like we've been we've been doing that
y'all know how the grind goes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like we're doing two days
three days four days for years and years
and years and then for it to get paid
paid off with champagne showers man yeah
it's a beautiful feeling yeah Bruce we
should let you go you've got celebrating
to do yeah there you go you can hang out
if you want some more drinking to do yes
sir it's your night kick it
congratulations you can see if you want
I figured you might want to go
you have no Freedom when you're on TV
we're all stuck to the chair whether we
want to be or not nice job
congratulations Aaron when you started
thinking about Miami what this series
would be when did you realize that that
mismatch stuff that we talked about was
going to be a factor for you oh well I
had played against Miami uh a few times
because I was in Orlando right you know
so that was kind of a rivalry in our own
right
um so when we got to play them we had to
match up I had a little bit of a
familiarity with them so I was able to
just kind of be a little bit more
comfortable because I had played them
before
when I look when I watch you play I just
watch how you guard in these playoffs
you've had some tough matchups you're
starting out with Ant-Man then you're
bouncing between Booker and Kevin Durant
now then you're guarding LeBron James
now you're here guarding Jimmy Butler
and you're not giving an edge but I
could see a difference in Jimmy Butler
especially with his aggression when you
are on him talk about how you attack
those matchups because every matchup was
its own separate War oh man what you
gotta you gotta know the strengths and
their weaknesses I feel like I have the
strength to kind of bump with them and
then the agility to kind of slide my
feet uh you know it's a team defense at
the same time but you know we got guys
like Nicola jokic and Jamal Murray and
Michael Porter that scored the ball so
well that if I if I play defense on this
side and let them make their job easy
you know I think we're going to be in a
good spot if we do that you know Aaron
we we talked when you were in Orlando
and and when you were making that
transition here
and you kept talking about how you
wanted to win how you wanted to be a
part of a championship organization
championship team and you wanted to feel
it because see the passion in your face
but more importantly I can see the hurt
in your face
tell us a little bit about now that
you're feeling the other side of that
Joy instead of that hurt that you were
feeling but it just makes me emotional
man yeah I mean you guys know how this
league is it's so up and down so to just
kind of just trying to stay even killed
and just keep climbing and keep climbing
and keep climbing uh to get to a point
uh where I have an opportunity to play
with such a great team and win a
championship like it just makes me
emotional in those down moments right
who were the you know who were the
people that that was that was keeping
you going that was that was encouraging
you saying one day it's going to be a
light at the end of the tunnel because
again you know nights like this all we
see is the light at the end of the
tunnel but I think it's important that
people understand and know the the
journey that all of you have taken to
get here
I have some great people in my life yeah
I have some good mentors in my life
um but I've been self-motivated from the
jump I've been self-motivated you know
what I mean since I was legit yeah and
um
it it was just about just showing up
just keep showing up keep showing up if
you have a bad game you have a good game
it doesn't matter keep showing up that's
half the battle if you if you bring
yourself there okay now now we can see
what happens now we can see what shakes
out we'll just show up yeah Aaron you
showed up tonight yes he did you know
they talk about something tonight we
talk about the Murray and Joker's pick
and roll but the combination of you and
Joker to look like y'all just have eye
contact to talk to me about your
relationship on the court that's really
not verbal it's wild because it's a it's
a point forward and a point Center
playing together
so it's it's different you know what I
mean it's it's a it's an evolution of
the game a little bit and um like Joker
is a center play or I mean a point guard
playing at seven foot one you know what
I mean so he understands how the offense
is supposed to work how the defensive
schemes are working and I see that too
because you know I I try and view the
game at the same way so we've been like
we've been just on point from like day
one I got here you know what I mean
we've just been able to see each other
and it's just gotten better and better
well it was a fun to watch
congratulations on the series on the
title on the ring coming your way you
got the champagne you got a cigar you
got goggles
23 much more coming up here